are you one of the people that believe  Rudy Giuliani and even Dick Cheney were  involved in it sure I believe that  really because I have heard enough about  it for instance so you believe Rudy  Giuliani played a part in 9 11 America's  mayor on 9 11 was the person the culprit  he had to be oh really yeah please  explain so and there are people who have  researched his complicity for one he had  foreknowledge of the buildings the Twin  Towers coming down and said we got  noticed that they're going to come down  well wait a minute what about the 400  and 343 firefighters they didn't get  notice that the building was coming down  so they could get out of there only he  had it this is on so what are the  chances that Rudy Giuliani had a major  part in 9 11. that's very high